how far long are you 21 weeks but there
was one time and it was lunch break and
Danny said to me says come to my trailer
I cook some good Italian food we come to
my trailer we smoke a stogy I take the
stogy that I'm going to give them and I
stick a little weed
in he
sayz I have a really good stoy look at
this so he knew that that my saliva was
running
together be lighted up and I'm smoking
it and it was fantastic we get to the
set I'm sitting in standing in front of
the camera it was a close-up on me and
uh the director says action and I said
uh uh uh you said can anyone help me
here what's the line he goes Arnold go
ahead say your line he
go